-Our next guest is an
Emmy Award-winning writer
who you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and the movie "Wine Country.
Her show "Bless the Harts"
airs on Sunday nights on Fox
Let's take a look.
-There she is!
The Paula Abdula of Greenpoint
-And the newest member
of the Carolina
Panther cheerleading squad
How'd the audition go?
-You guys, I'm sure
I didn't get it.
Some of those girls have dance
on cruise ships.
-Hush, Jenny, you're getting
the hell out of Greenpoint
You'll spend a year or two
as a Panthers girl,
then go the J.Lo route.
Seduce a music producer,
make a mint for all of us,
then star in an epic flop
with Ben Affleck
and come out even stronger
-And once you make the team,
I'm coming with
because you're going to need
an entourage,
you know, like that HBO show -
"Arliss."
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Emily Spivey.
How you doing, Spives?
-Hi! I'm doing so good, Seth
It's so good to see you,
oh, my God.
-It is so good
to see you as well.
We started on the same day
at "SNL" in 2001.
And I will -- You know,
if you don't like watching
two people reminisce, you know
flip over to somewhere els
because we had
great years together.
But I'm wondering if you,
watching the show this year,
if you wish that you'd bee
writing there during this
election cycle or dreading it?
-Ooh, I have mixed feelings.
I mean, how do you feel?
I felt relieved that
I could just watch it.
Because as you know, we did --
you made T-shirts, Seth.
It was called the Gauntlet
We did 8 ep-- wait, or was i
10 episodes of 8 weeks, right?
-Yeah, I think it was
10 episodes in 8 weeks
because we were doing
"The Weekend Updates" Thursdays.
-And I, of course, was
weirdly pregnant.
It's not we're weird
to be pregnant
but it felt weird to be pregnant
during this time,
and I had morning sickness
and was just sitting there
going, "Ooh, whew, whew."
But at the same time
it was amazing
because I remember sitting
with Paula and Tina
in that weird, little, tin
office on nine,
watching Tina rehearse
doing Sarah Palin.
So it was like, you know,
you're part of history.
But still, ooh! No, no.
-Yeah. I mean, the fact that
they did six Saturdays in a row,
I am not jealous of at all
But I really do think they did
an incredible job.
-And you were a hero, Seth
You really --
I mean, listen to me.
You deserve -- Emmys should be
raining down on you
for the work you did on that
-Oh, please stop.
-I mean, come on.
-We talk a lot about
Second Chance Theater
with my old cohorts of the show.
-Yes.
-What are some of your worst
most delicious bombs
under the bleachers with Lorne
-Oh, my God.
There's almost
too many to count.
-What was Chicken McNugs?
-Well, Chicken McNugs was --
Okay, it was --
Matt Dillon was the host.
And he was sort of a hot sho
boyfriend to Rachel Dratch
who was sort of playing
like a little --
you know, a girl
with lots of cats
and scented candles
who couldn't get a boyfriend
So he broke up with her
in a miserable way.
So then she just hauls it
to McDonald's
and buys 500,000 chicken
McNuggets,
all sauces, and it became
a musical, alright?
I've never seen Lorne so angry
[ Laughter ]
He said -- it was just --
it's so -- you know,
it was one of those things
where he was so upset.
And by the way, I was upset too.
I don't -- I don't blame Lorne
But he did throw -- he threw
the headsets on the floor.
Again, I don't blame him.
And then I was like,
"Okay, I'm out."
I walked to the elevators.
First I walked up
to Maya's office,
got my backpack and my coat,
went down to the street,
held up my little hand,
was about to get a cab.
And then I got a call.
"Lorne wants to see you."
So I went back up,
and he apologized.
But still, I felt terrible
The whole thing was a disaster
But -- I don't know.
That is -- that was the wors
day. It's a really sad story
Happy birthday, Lorne,
by the way.
I hope you had a good birthday
[ Laughter ]
-It should be noted.
I mean, it is --
it is intensely stressful
to be underneath
the bleachers with Lorne.
-Oh, my God.
-You mentioned the headset
He is wearing a headset
that is plugged
directly into the monitor.
-Yes.
-So that he can get --
he can just like mainline
the sketch into his ears.
-Yes, so he's hearing it
and I'm kind of not hearing it
Yeah, and so -- and then David
McWilson was another sketc
where Rachel Dratch
played a little boy,
and Lorne, it was --
she played a child actor,
and it was real quiet.
And Lorne turned to me
in the middle of it,
and he was like,
"This is almost Brechtian"
in a withering way,
and I was like,
"I don't really even know
what that means,
but I know it's not good."
I mean, I know Brecht.
But anyway.
So there was just a lot of -
Ooh, so many --
so many hot farts
under that bleachers,
'cause the nerves,
it was terrible.
-I should note,
lest anybody should doubt,
that you also had monster hits
in your time on the show.
-Oh, Seth, you're so sweet
-You and Maya were friends
at The Groundlings.
You wrote Donatella Versace.
-Oh, God.
-I mentioned to you
I ran into her recently.
And I only sort of --
I had no awareness of her
until you did this sketch.
And she was very complimentary
She enjoyed it.
-She did.
She had a very good
sense of humor.
You know, as --
I think Europeans have bette
sense of humors
about themselves, you know
Like, she thought it was
very funny and adored Maya
She gave us both
very expensive watches.
Which, one, I still have
but I can't wear it
because it's bananas-looking
[ Laughter ]
By the way, Hugh Grant.
I mean, can you stand it?
He is so cute.
-You -- One thing that I kno
you've used some of your writing
for and some
of the rejected sketches,
and I've talked to Amy Poehler
about this, Tina Fey about this.
There is a text chain of women
who worked on the show
that I was lucky enough
to cross over with.
And you guys did a Zoom
talent show with your children
that is already legendary.
-Is it? I wish it was.
Yeah. I -- my son, Rowe,
won that talent show.
He did a very confusing sketch
that I had written
for Steve Martin.
And, Seth, it was such
a Spivey special.
I don't mean to talk
about myself in third person
But it was called -- it was,
"Are you looking
for a rocking good time
with stick-to-your-ribs
grub and entertainment?
Well, need to get yourself
down to Rocking R's
and Captain T's smoking ribs
and stuffing blues and such.
So the idea was just this
ridiculous restaurant
where you poked,
you know --
you ate mashed potatoes
out of an old boot,
or you poked a donkey
in the eye.
Like, it was just stupid.
And Rowe went on and read
all these crazy lines
to a group of amazing,
I mean -- how did I
even get in this group?
Andrea Martin, Tina Fey,
Paula Pell, Jon Hamm.
And he was amazing
and he won the talent show
according to all the Tanglets,
which is what we call
the Tang kids, the Tanglets.
-Now, it should be noted
the Tang is...?
-It is a text chain that I hav
with Paula Pell, Tina Fey,
Ana Gasteyer, Rachel Dratch,
Maya Rudolph, and me.
Who am I leaving out?
Amy Poehler.
-It's a pretty good group
of people.
-It's the funnest.
I don't know what I would --
the funnest.
I don't know would what I
would do without it.
I would not get through
this, like, turd hoagie
that is 2020 without the Tang.
-The funnest.
There you are
being Brechtian again.
-Oh, so Brechtian.
He was so withering
when he said that.
I was like, "Can I kill myself?"
-I remember you and Amy
at the read-through table
were close enough
that you could pass notes.
-Yes.
-I was right next to Dratch.
Dratch and I were note sharers
-Yes.
-It was a great gift
because those were the mos
stressful times of the week.
-Oh, my God, horrible.
-Were your note passing days
with Poehler wonderful?
-Oh, my God, they were so w-
well, you know --
like, constantly --
Also, Seth, next time I'm on
or maybe at my funeral
when you're speaking
at my funeral,
I'll read what you -- 'cause
we used to pass notes too.
But my favorite note that
Poehler ever passed me was
I think, you know, "Jostie" --
Colin Jost used to come in
looking like
he'd run through sprinkler
all the way to 30 Rock.
And his hair was soak--
you know, that beautiful
head of hair, soaking wet.
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "Jostie, what the
hell are you doing anyway?
So he came in sopping wet.
It was like a Jost
wet T-shirt contest
'cause he just had
on a white shirt.
You could see his nips
and his chest hair.
And then me and Poehler
were like, "Oh."
And then Poehler passed me
a note that said,
"I like Jostie in the arm area."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know. I feel like
somebody should read that
at Jost's funeral.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen, maybe we'll be
buried together.
You know what, Seth, is Jost -
listen, Seth, is Jost okay
'Cause I'm worried.
-Why are you worried?
-Because like --
Can he find a girlfriend?
How is his career going?
-Oh. Oh!
I don't know if you've heard
He's doing excellent.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
But tell me what's going on.
Oh, please,
Jost, are you okay, baby?
-I think he's doing just fine.
And I also -- you know,
even in that clip, we hear
some of our friends --
obviously in "Bless the Harts.
That was Kristen. That was Maya.
And I know you have
some great guest voices
coming up this year as well.
-Oh, my God, we have so many
We have Holly Hunter.
We have Mary Steenburgen,
who is my heart.
We have Jon Hamm.
Jon Hamm's Jon Hamm,
which is one of my favorit
Seth sketches.
We have Sal Vulcano
from "Impractical Jokers."
-Yeah, the Jokers.
-I'm obsessed with
"Impractical Jokers."
Obsessed.
Who else do we have?
Natasha Lyonne and Fred Armisen.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-Well, Spivey, needless to say
it is always wonderful
seeing you.
You're the best.
-So are you, Sethly.
-I love you.
-I love you too, babe.
Oh, my God, Seth, I love you
And I love this show.
Will you put this on the show?
You got me through 2020.
-You're too kind.
-Seriously, your "Closer Looks
and everything else,
it's like the voice of reason.
I love you so much.
-I'll see you
on the other side, Spive.
-Alright.
-"Bless the Harts" airs Sunday
on Fox.